okay as part of my quest to expose fake
history especially when it comes to
Islam let's take a look at a rather
interesting quote from the academic John
Esposito and if you don't know who he is
let me read to you a little bit about
him uh uh this information is compiled
from various websites including
Wikipedia basically John Esposito is an
award-winning professor of Islamic
studies at Georgetown University author
of more than 35 books on Islam
editorinchief of numerous Oxford
reference works including the Oxford
Encyclopedia of the modern Islamic world
and the Oxford history of Islam adviser
to the award-winning PBS documentary
Muhammad Legacy of a prophet and perhaps
most notably he's a go-to expert
certainly in his Heyday in the early
2000s following 9/11 when he was
frequently called onto brief government
agencies including the state department
FBI CIA Department of Homeland in
security and various branches of the
military so clearly this man knows his
Islam here's also a little fun fact
yours truly was a student at Georgetown
University some 25 years ago at the
center for contemporary Arab studies and
I do recall seeing him around and he was
essentially treated like a dawn you know
his word was law when it came to Islam
so let's take a look at some of his
words and see how lawful they are so let
me read to you an exerpt from one of his
books Islam the straight path this comes
from page 64 pay attention especially to
the first
part five centuries of peaceful
coexistence elapsed before political
events and an imperial papal Power Play
Led to centuries long series of
so-called Holy Wars that pitted
Christendom against Islam and left an
enduring Legacy of misunderstanding and
distrust I can't begin to tell you you
how utterly preposterous this statement
is but that's the purpose of this video
so bear with me here we go basically
what Esposito is saying in this exert is
that from the very beginning from the
dawn of Islam in the year 622 ad uh that
year corresponds with the year one of
the Islamic calendar 622 ad until the
first crusade which was called for in
the year
1095 and we're talking about uh 473
years I believe not exactly five
centuries but that's fine he's he's
rounding it off he's saying that all
that time the relationship between
Christians and Muslims was one of
peaceful
coexistence until Imperial people power
play decided to call for the First
Crusade and the rest is history
misunderstanding and grievances from
Muslims so this claim obscenely ignores
the cataclysmic and foundational events
that took place during that those five
centuries of peaceful coexistence
in just the first century following
Muhammad's death which is in the year
632 until 732 at the Battle of Tours
Islam through violent jihadist Conquest
annexed three4 of what was once the
Christian world if you looked at a map
the Middle East in its entirety to use
the modern names Syria Lebanon Jordan
Israel um Iraq all of that was Christian
as was Turkey but we'll get into that
um and all of North Africa so from Egypt
all the way Westward Libya Tunisia
Algeria Morocco all of that was actually
the heart of the Christian world the
four major christian Seas other than
Rome were all there Antioch Alexandria
Constantinople and um Jerusalem and all
of that was violently conquered in the
name of Islam in that first century the
sources from the period talk about Mass
massacres of Christians Mass enslavement
the destruction of thousands of churches
okay and this goes on all throughout
North Africa in the Middle East at the
hands of Muslims following the death of
Muhammad and Muhammad himself called for
this two years before he died he ordered
the uh Eastern Roman Emperor herculis to
submit to Islam and he of course he
didn't and War was declared or Jihad
okay and it's also interesting that
especially in the Islamic sources in the
Islamic historiographical tradition that
these wars are presented as jihads in
other words the reason Muslims did that
that they conquered this large swath of
Christian territory 3/4 of it is because
Christians were infidels and Islam
commands the conquest of infidel
territory and giving them their three
choices convert or become a themi pay
tribute Etc or fight to the death again
this was just the first of Esposito's
five centuries of peaceful coexistence
that's what happened now we can get into
all the other centuries from that point
until the first crusade those five
centuries but there's no time in this
video I hope eventually to actually make
more detailed videos looking perhaps
even into every country how it was
conquered and what the original sources
say but suffice to say it's more or less
the same thing in just the year 109 the
ftim khif Hakim Allah according to
Muslim sources I'm stressing this it's
not according to evil Christian sources
he destroyed 30,000 churches in the
Middle East in egyp Egypt and greater
Syria which of course again is a
reflection of how Christian that region
was that's what the sources say that's
in from elmi the uh Muslim historian but
it's also found in other Islamic sources
as well so at any rate let's fast
forward to just a few decades before the
first crusade which is still part of
Esposito's five centuries of peaceful
coexistence because he's saying
everything before the the first crusade
in 1095 was peaceful coexistence okay so
a lot lot of the quotes I'm going to
read to you are from Matthew of adessa a
contemporary he was an Armenian
historian who actually ended up being
killed uh at the sack of adessa in 1144
which presaged the Second Crusade but
his source is invaluable his uh his
Chronicle and it's a contemporary again
eyewitness account for many of the
events now he writes that in the year
1019 quote the first appearance of the
bloodthirsty beasts The Savage Nation of
Turks entered Armenia
and mercilessly slaughtered the
Christian faithful with the
sword and then in 1049 the Turks reached
the unwalled city of Arsen and quote put
the whole town to the sword causing
severe Slaughter as many as 150,000
persons
unquote uh regarding Arsen the sack of
Arsen another eyewitness aristois the
Greek writes quote without Mercy they
the Turks incinerated those who had
hidden themselves in houses and churches
end quot
it took 800 oxen and 40 camels to cart
out the vast plunder from Arsen mostly
taken from the churches about 800 all of
which were systematically torched to the
ground once they were plundered and the
Muslims left here's another one during
the Turkish Siege of sebastia in modern
day SAS Asia Minor Anatolia turkey and
this happened in 1060 600 churches were
destroyed and quote many women and
children were led into captivity unquote
another raid on Armenian territory
around that same time saw quote many and
innumerable people who were burned to
death end quote between 1064 and 1065
Sultan Muhammad bin D shagi better known
amongst fawning westerners as Alp arsin
the Brave Lion the Turkish selic Sultan
he besieged Ani the capital of Armenia
at the time and once inside the Turks
quote began to mercilessly Slaughter the
inhabitants of the entire city and
piling up their bodies one on top of the
other innumerable and countless boys
with bright faces and pretty little
girls were carried off together with
their mothers unquote not only do
Christian sources document the sack of
ani often in apocalyptic terms but so do
some Muslim ones according to One Source
an Arabic man writes quote I wanted to
enter the city and see it with my own
eyes after it was sacked I tried to find
the street without having to walk over
the corpses but that was possible that
comes from Alfred Friendly's book The
Dreadful day about the Battle of
manaker nor was there much doubt what
fueled these Turks animist towards the
Christians of Armenia according to a man
just known only as David and he's in
Matthew of adessa Chronicles he said to
his countrymen the following quote this
nation of infidels the Turks comes
against us because of our Christian
faith and they are intent on destroying
the worshippers of the Cross and on
Exterminating the Christian faith
faithful therefore it is fitting and
right for all the faithful to go forth
with their swords and to die for the
Christian faith which is what they did
to no avail they all got slaughtered and
enslaved now as the Turks moved Westward
into Asia Minor or Anatolia they visited
the same sorts of atrocities on the
Greeks Mass Slaughter mass enslavement
and destruction of churches here's what
the Eastern Roman emperor of the time
Alexius I wrote to his friend Robert of
Flanders who himself would be
participate in the First Crusade the
emperor wrote
quote the holy places are desecrated and
destroyed in countless ways Noble
mothers and their daughters robbed of
everything are violated one after
another like animals some of their
rapists shamelessly Place virgins in
front of their own mothers and forc them
both to sing Wicked and obscene songs
until they have finished having their
ways with them men of every age and
description boys youths old men Nobles
peasants and what is still worse to hear
clerics and monks and woe of
unprecedented woes even Bishops are
defiled with the sin of sodomy meaning
they were being raped and gang raped and
this is actually recorded in various and
many sources not just uh from the
emperor and so after the passage of this
these five centuries of peaceful
coexistence we finally come to the
origins of the First Crusade at the
Council of Clermont in 1095 in France
Pope Urban the second said the following
in an assembly amongst the Christians
many of them who were
Knights Pope Urban said quote they
Muslim Turks have completely destroyed
some of God's churches and they have
converted others to the uses of their
own cult meaning they made the mosques
they ruined the altars with filth and
defilement they circumcised Christians
and smear the blood from the
circumcision over the altars or throw it
into the baptismal fonts they are
pleased to kill others by by cutting
open their bellies extracting the end of
their intestines and tying it to a stake
then with fogging they drive their
victims around the Stak until when their
viscera have spilled out they fall dead
on the ground they tie others again to
stakes and shoot arrows at them they
seize others stretch out their necks and
try to see whether they can cut off
their heads with a single blow of a
naked sword and what shall I say of the
shocking rape of women who is to repair
this damage if you do not do it rise up
and remember the manly Deeds of your
ancestors
and at that point this is when all the
Christians in assembly most of them like
I said Knights stood up and said deos
vult God wills it and the First Crusade
of History was off ruining those five
peaceful centuries of coexistence that
preceded it so now you know what was
really happening before and led directly
to the First Crusade during John
Esposito's otherwise five centuries of
peaceful coexistence between Muslims and
Christians I should add that the only
time that John Esposito tries to address
this question of what Muslims were doing
to Christians is a few sentences after
the exerpt I read in fact he basically
mocks when the knights got up and said
deos F God wills it he writes as
follows this was ironic that the knights
Cried Out deos vult because as one
scholar has observed God May indeed have
wished it but there is certainly no
evidence that the Christians of
Jerusalem did or that anything
extraordinary was occurring to pilgrims
there to prompt such a response at that
moment in history scholar that Esposito
is quoting is Francis e Peters in an
essay he wrote called early Muslim
empires now clearly this academic is
just as delusional if not dishonest as
John Esposito to claim that nothing was
happening to Christian pilgrims in the
Years leading up to the First Crusade is
itself
extraordinary here for example is what
Michael the Syrian another temporary
chronicler and eyewitness of the times
Rights was
happening as the Turks were ruling the
lands of Syria and Palestine they
inflicted injuries on Christians who
went to pray in Jerusalem they beat them
pillaged them and levied the pole tax
jiza in other words they extorted them
of money moreover every time they saw a
caravan of Christians particularly those
coming from Rome in the lands of Italy
they made every effort to cause their
death in diverse ways or consider what
happened to this large German pilgrimage
to the Holy Land in the year 1064
according to one of its survivors quote
accompanying this journey was a noble
abis a head none of graceful body and of
a religious Outlook setting aside the
cares of the sisters committed to her
and against the advice of the wise she
undertook this great and dangerous
pilgrimage the pagans the Muslims
captured her and in the sight of all
these Shameless men gang raped her until
she breathed her last to the dishonor of
all Christians Christ's enemies
performed such abuses and others like
them on the Christians end quote so
there it is the truth about John
Esposito's five centuries of peaceful
coexistence between Muslims and
Christians until those evil European
Christians ruined it all by launching
the First Crusade let me read to you
that exerpt again so you can remember it
pay attention five centuries of peaceful
coexistence elapsed before political
events and an imperial papal Power Play
Led to centuries long series of
so-called Holy Wars that pitted
Christendom against Islam and left an
enduring Legacy of misunderstanding and
distrust which is why of course Muslims
have Grievances and engage in terrorism
today etc etc that's the sort of thing
he tells all those governmental
agencies all right now ask yourself this
if Esposito and so many other academics
and experts just like him who are
regularly consulted including by
governmental intelligence and Military
agencies can lie so flagrantly about
five entire centuries in an effort to
blame Christians for starting
hostilities with Muslims what else are
they lying about when it comes to the
relationship between Islam and the West